a New Zealand prime minister Jacinda
ardern did an extraordinarily good job
of pointing to a reporter's very silly
question and saying would you be asking
me that question if I was a 60 year old
man instead of a younger woman this is
super interesting and we're going to
look at the clip New Zealand prime
minister Jacinda ardern was um doing a
joint press conference with the Finnish
prime minister Santa Marin both female
leaders
younger than being in their 60s or 70s
as is common in many parts around the
world and the reporter asked
why are you meeting is it because you're
both younger women and Jacinda ardern
among pointing out many other problems
with the question said is that a
question you would ask about why other
world leaders meet let's take a look at
this this was very nicely handled yeah a
lot of people will be wondering are you
two meeting a lot by the way a lot of
people will be wondering is that
actually true or is this just a code for
I want to ask this question no matter
what and so I'm saying other people want
to know who's wondering about that here
we go yeah a lot of people will be
wondering are you two meeting just
because you know you're similar in age
and you know got a lot of you know
Common stuff there you know when you got
into politics and stuff or can kiwis
actually expect to see more deals
between our two countries down the line
because there is something my first
question is I wonder whether or not
anyone ever asked Barack Obama or John
key if they met because they were of
similar Age
We of course have a higher purpose of
meaning politics it's reality because
two women meet it's not simply because
of the agenda Finland exports into a New
Zealand 199 million dollars worth of
exports they have particular technology
in companies like Nokia biofuels even
basic industrial Wares that we use in
our buildings you won't be aware that a
large number of our elevators come out
of Finland agricultural Machinery New
Zealand on the other hand is trading
about 14 million dollars worth and it's
mostly in wine and beef there is huge
potential between us the EU FTA is a
launch pad for that but we need to make
sure that as Nations we don't just
simply go through the motions of a FTA
ratification but that is individual
Nations we look for the opportunities to
build on that economic agreement so for
me this is timely next year we're
looking to progress that FTA our meeting
today is a chance alongside the prime
minister's high level trade delegation
of significant industry leaders we
really leverage the economic
opportunities between our two countries
little would be known about the depth of
that relationship or the potential of it
but it's our job to further it
regardless of our gender
yeah we are meeting because we are prime
ministers of course but as Jacinda said
uh we have a I think you get the point
this is really a perfect example of the
type of question that she gets because
of her age and gender and I think it's
really important you know this is not a
show
it's important to me that this is not a
show that uncritically repeats tropes
that are not actually true so when the
all you don't hear this too much anymore
but there was a while where it was 77
cents on the dollar women make 77 cents
on the dollar compared to men and if I'm
going to be using that I want to know
that that's actually accurate and so we
researched it we spent a while doing the
research we did a long form piece on it
and we found out that really we're
talking about 92 cents on the dollar
when we look at the gender pay Gap some
part of that Gap presumably due to
gender discrimination and part of it due
to other factors so that's the number I
use I want to have the actual data
this is just a perfect example of a
question that you're not going to get
you know when when Trump and who's a
70-something year old world world leader
I don't know I mean listen Putin's not
70 something I think he's close to 70.
but when Trump and Putin meet no one
thinks to say are you meeting because
you're both white men of a similar age
no nobody would ask that in any other
circumstance like this in fact when you
see someone like Trudeau and macron meet
younger men nobody's asking about
whether they're meeting because of their
age either so I think it's really
important that we not say that there are
isms when they aren't actually there
that were accurate with the claims that
we make Etc this is just straight up a
question that she's getting and that
they are getting both of the Finnish and
New Zealand prime minister they are
getting these questions because of their
age and gender plain and simple